growing poverty is pushing lebanese
people back onto the streets
protesters say they are hungry unable to
cope with a coronavirus lockdown
now in its third week they want economic
support
this is how the authorities responded
the politicians are focusing on
distributing the spoils instead of
focusing on
us we are witnessing a collapse in all
sectors
security politics and health they are
all irresponsible
they are leaving us to die lebanon's
economic collapse began more than a year
ago
there have been social unrest and
political turmoil since
officials say 500 000 families or 2.5
million people
are in need of assistance that's nearly
half the population
compliance with a 24-hour curfew that
exempts essential workers
is weak in lebanon's second largest city
tripoli
it was already poor before the pandemic
these people are obliged to work even
though it puts their health at risk
other governments are enforcing
lockdowns but they give people aid
there is no social safety net for the
poor no government assistance
the state is nearly bankrupt one third
of the workforce
is jobless and around half of the
workforce depends on daily wages
like abu he has four children
no shop and on a good day he makes
twenty thousand lebanese pounds
which is less than three dollars at the
black market rate
nothing you also flick here life has
become so hard
i can't even describe it i'm barely able
to feed my family
while others can't even do that
charity associations say more and more
people are relying on handouts
among them the middle class the cost of
daily life is becoming too high
especially since the local currency's
value collapsed
on a daily basis we have people that
would like to register because of course
we register them
according to nationality and location
so i must say that the numbers are
increasing on a daily basis
the open-ended political crisis is not
helping politicians are arguing about
cabinet seats instead of agreeing to
fight corruption allowing lebanon to
receive much-needed international
financial assistance
the lockdown is in place until february
8 and it can be extended
officials are promising to help the most
vulnerable and are asking people to be
patient
but for many that's not an option
al jazeera tripoli northern lebanon